[Applause]
no although it feels like friends never
went away like there was all of friends
it took a beat
and then it started rearing again and i
feel like the cycle of friends is
something that we've never
been without and you must be getting
hounded so much
about the reunion of friends which was
delayed
because of the pandemic but oh my god
we've all been on the feeder of this as
if it's like
life juice
oh yeah well we we did the reunion
and it's it's an unscripted
with lots of surprises and we all got to
gather
on stage 24 at warner brothers and
that's the first time we've done that
and
since the show ended so it's very
emotional and i
i just ah it was great
does it feel like there's been a gap in
time when you see everybody together
on stage 24 yeah i mean
um we'll always have an incredible bond
that will that feels like
we're like this everybody's just so
excited for this reunion do they swear
you to secrecy
honestly i'm trying to think of how do i
answer a question without
getting in trouble how do you yeah how
do you talk about the friends reunion
without talking about the friends
reunion
unscripted reunion stage 24
surprises that's all i got uh
but thank you we're all looking so
forward to that
and um okay so nine months with courtney
cox
like this is the third season i just
watched the trailer for season three
which is out now
and talking about pregnancy
uh whether it was miscarriages or
what it takes for people to fight to get
pregnant and
ivf and all of these experiences
you know why did you feel compelled to
tap into
something that is very
private quiet and not spoken about
well originally um
how it started was um my producing
partners ample entertainment
had through my agent sent a sizzle reel
but i watched the sizzle reel of of
of nine months and i was like i called
immediately i have to be
involved in the show and the reason why
is i
it's so honest it's you know
everyone films themselves it's not
scripted no one's telling you what to do
um or how to behave they're just
real and i think it's really important
for people to know that they're not
alone i mean we have every single
walk of life we have you know um couples
just
arranged with like the clip that you're
gonna show hopefully is um
a teenage couple that decided to have a
child and it was
they didn't plan it but um it's an
incredible
experience to watch and you pull for
these people
and i'm ver i'm really proud of it we
actually have the clip you just
mentioned let's take a look
maddie is pregnant
you're 17 she's 16 and you're still in
my house
do you realize that you were a young
white
young lady that's about to give birth to
a black child
and are you ready for everything that
comes with that
when i find i was pregnant with this
baby that was definitely not the thought
that came to mind
the fact that comes to mind is just this
is terrifying i don't
i don't know how i'm gonna do this but
i'm gonna love
my baby no matter what well i think you
made such a
brilliant choice by making it such an
intimate setting because you're just
going to get
an intimacy that you won't get with a
crew
being there um but what the heck is
going on
with scream i'm dying to know
it will scream you know this is the
fifth one it's not screening five though
this
is scream these directors and
they these guys are just the directors
are incredible they're making it
absolutely it's a new franchise it's
it's hip it's scary it's it's just a new
screen
it's not it's not a reboot it's not a
remake it's
just a brand new launch i think it's
gonna be fantastic
i'm so excited for it and you just took
me back to being in sonoma
california um shooting the very first
scream oh my god gosh the opening of
that movie i mean if you guys haven't
seen it you have to see drew an opening
of scream it
is one of the best performances ever
you're you're
an unbelievable that means so much as a
fellow
alumni of what became a gigantic
franchise movie it was such an original
script
such a fresh concept and i'm so glad
that it's come full circle
and long live scream i know
gosh kevin williamson he was a writer
and he's
he just created something that's never
been done
i know it's so cool well i'm glad to
have lived
a hollywood life with you to be a mom um
who asks you questions and advice to be
a scream alumni and to just be a woman
who also is like
the ultimate courtney cox fan i mean
seriously well i feel the same way and i
i hope i get to see you in person soon
i hope so too more than anything thank
you so much and season
three of nine months with courtney cox
is out now
on facebook watch and new episodes air
every sunday
and thursday at 5 p.m 4 p.m central
[Music]
you